from the people that you've interviewed
from meeting Jay Shaffer and then also
seeing your own lives what do you notice
as a common theme among tiny house
owners and not just sort of the love of
a small space or wanting to preserve you
know resources and not acquire too many
possessions was sort of a common maybe
mindset of everyone that's I think one
one interesting thing is I mean
especially because we were coming at it
from sort of an environmental
sustainability perspective but almost
everyone that we've interviewed even if
that's sort of in their mind as well are
coming at it from more of a financial
quality of life perspective and a lot of
people you know are living in tiny
houses as a way to you know own their
home outright with no mortgage and you
know getting out of debt and things like
that and i think you know that's that's
kind of been a cot in a common theme and
i think also just quality of life I mean
people not simplifying so that they can
fit into this small space but it's
almost like living in the small space is
a byproduct of this you know long
process of downsizing that they've gone
through already and you know really just
wanting to prioritize the quality of
relationships and the people on their
lives and you know the things that they
like to do rather than the things they
like to have it definitely says shift in
the mindset where their house becomes a
means to an end rather than the end
itself and I think that that's pretty
common amongst them do you think the
tiny house movement might be an answer
to so many people's fears about
retirement I know for me Generation X we
don't even know if Social Security will
exist at retirement age do you think
this is a solution for that so that
people don't have to worry about whether
or not they'll be able to pay rent while
they're in their 60s and find a job at
that age yeah I think that you know
we've heard from several people that
there are debt free now because you know
they've only been living in their tiny
houses for two or three years but
because it when you're not paying a
mortgage every month you know it's six
hundred to a thousand dollars to two
thousand dollars in some cases
or more that that you can put towards
paying bills or putting into your
retirement so it is can very well be a
key to financial independence for long
term as well but I think it really
depends you know it's like anything else
it's up to the person and what they
choose to do with that extra money so
and you know if you built the tiny house
right it can last as long as a normal
house it's bill very pretty much the
same way so it you know it it could last
you in to old age and you could live in
it that long suppose you
you